Five four,
three,
two.
Welcome everybody to the h three beyond
the experience podcast.
Thank you to dollar Shave Club,
men mobile and express vpn today for
sponsoring us.
That guests of course the great bill
burr that's here today or about Greg,
give me some of the greatest,
greatest guy sitting across from you
right now.
I know pretty much can close the show I
think.
Yeah,
there you go.
Thank you.
Thanks guys.
And that'll be all.
Um,
first of all,
very excited for you playing Madison
Square Garden November 7th.
Yes sir.
You guys can go get,
take it now.
Bill.
billboard.com/events.
Yeah.
B U R R a fee.
You are,
I also want to give you credit for,
I mean F is for family.
Oh yeah,
we just uh,
wrapped I guess production is when you
call on season three.
So that should be out on Netflix later
on this year.
They haven't given me a date yet.
They have some sort of
probably in November cause everything
you have a lot going on in November.
You've got your new movie coming out.
The front runner.
I got thanksgiving.
Do you got Thanksgiving out?
Fuck you.
I know you got rivalry weekend.
The NCAA,
there's a lot going on for the great
bill burr,
but Madison Square Garden.
That's crazy.
Is that your,
have you played that venue before?
Yeah,
one of the time.
Uh,
I forget one.
2015 I played it.
Mm.
So now back.
And uh,
hopefully just as good,
if not better than the last time.
How does it feel?
Cause that there's like almost 21,000
seats.
None.
How does it feel playing to that many
people?
Verse like 200 People in Comedy Club?
It depends on how see
it like,
so when I did it,
I had the stage onto one side,
but now this time I'm doing it in the
round so it's more seats.
I don't know how,
I don't know how many it is,
but uh,
it's,
you know,
what I did the first time was I ended
up,
um,
you know,
cause I'm a big Zeplin fan and a song
remains the same.
You know,
the concert film was shot there,
so I played drums.
So me and the guys from the Goddamn
comedy jam,
Josh,
Adam Meyers and all those guys,
Ben Bailey came down,
my publicist played drums.
We all just in the ld arena just jammed
and all these guns and roses and rock
songs that we grew up with.
Then it was fun.
It turned it into like sort of like a,
um,
it felt like a more like,
uh,
like,
you know,
our clubhouse for the day.
And uh,
yeah,
you went in,
you made a lot of noise and then it
didn't,
it didn't seem as crazy.
So I went out there and Paul versey
opened and then Joe Derosa was on,
Joe had this old sort of what I was
calling it,
a golden girl's sweater on.
So I w I just made fun of that,
you know,
keep going,
Paul Verhoeven and Joe to rose with his
fucking golden girls sweater.
Just made me feel like I was at a comedy
club,
you know?
Hmm.
And then I had nervous fan at first
show.
I was like,
that's still,
you know,
like,
I mean I get more like I want people to
feel like they got their money's worth.
Like I want people to leave.
Like you feel like,
uh,
like nervousness and all that is,
is on the way up.
And then once you get to a certain
level,
then it becomes like responsibility.
Like these people spent their hard
earned money coming out.
Yeah.
To get a sitter and it's not like they
just went to a comedy club,
hey,
let's watch 10 comics and maybe a couple
of drinks.
Yeah,
I have a couple of,
yeah,
this is like,
this is an event.
So now the pressure in that,
uh,
no,
I mean,
I mean it's,
it would be a lot of pressure if I had
to do like math,
like something I wasn't good at,
but it's like,
this is what I do.
They're coming to see me.
I mean,
you could do a podcast there.
No,
no,
you'd be fine.
Well,
I guess you're not in front of a crowd,
but whatever,
you know what I mean?
If you went to the,
to whatever comic con podcasting,
would you be nervous?
Yes.
All right.
Well [inaudible] nervous.
Got,
I'm so neurotic.
I am nervous.
I'm nervous right now.
Okay.
Very nervous.
I don't think about that and help build
trust.
I'm well,
I'm on the edge.
Was there a relaxed thank you God.
Okay.
Keep it together.
Was there a point when you kind of pick
a,
certainly you felt nervousness sometime?
Oh No.
Yeah,
the first eight years of my career,
I mean I would be like,
I'd do a 10 minute spot and then on
nights where it was a difficult crowd in
New York,
I would be out of breath and sweating
really 12 minutes.
I was telling jokes and it would be
sweaty show.
Yeah,
no,
no.
I had on,
I had all these rituals.
I this referral for years where before I
went on stage I would untie and then
retire my shoes cause I always worried
what if they came on time and I did a
face plant.
Oh wait,
I have,
should have that kind of OCD shit.
It drives me crazy.
I don't know if that's OCD,
but,
well,
I depends on what your childhood was.
I mean,
if you had a childhood and you weren't
bullied at all and you still think like
that,
I would think it was some sort of ocd,
but you know,
he got kicked out of yours for a while
ago.
So city you're kind of looking at,
oh,
your Z.
I don't know.
I'm not going to diagnose you.
I have no idea.
Yeah.
So in my case it was probably just,
you know,
my childhood or whatever and it's just
like,
oh,
you got bullied as a kid.
Yeah.
Oh,
both.
I did bully I,
you know,
it was,
yeah,
get it off of me and I'd pick on
somebody weaker than me.
You know,
it was the Lord of the flies back then.
So it wasn't the way it is now where,
um,
you know,
you can go on Youtube and the next thing
the bullies crying for some reason.
Like,
I feel like bullies almost important in
a way,
isn't it?
Like you got to allow kids to give each
other shit in a sense.
I mean you can't call it a kids too
much.
I don't think as a parent you ever allow
it?
Sure.
You know it's,
it's something though.
But I mean I know that there's like a,
like I have a daughter,
I want her to take some mma and I,
I just think all women should know that
because I feel like rapists,
you know,
depending on how well they're in doubt,
at some point they're going to have to
get in close.
And I feel like no one killer.
Yeah.
I mean,
yeah,
it's like,
I would think like when you watch those
women fighting in the UFC,
it's just like this,
I mean this probably,
I mean I would think what I have,
what percentage of the population of
just guys that even know how to fight
sure could beat them and like I don't
think they could because the second you
get close to him and he's a professional
level fighters,
so if I'm,
the average woman would learn that.
I mean,
you could get them in a triangle.
The arms are,
when I said the armed guard,
I'm trying to remember all this stuff.
Rogan says like,
I don't,
I'm not educated in it,
but I just know looking at it that you
just like learn a little self defense
just enough that you can be on your back
and be in a powerful position.
And I just figured like a guy's going to
try to gorillas weigh in and try to hold
you down or whatever.
And then all of a sudden he's,
you know,
he's tapping out,
you blow out his elbow and,
and that's an erection killer right
there,
man.
You blow up the elbow as it,
I think that's slang for the arm bar.
See yet that's part of,
I feel like that's a new thing.
You're already worried about your
daughter being sexually assaulted.
You know,
how old is your daughter?
I don't think that is,
I think that's you projecting your ocd
on me.
It's all we you're talking about,
you know,
you want your,
your two year old daughter to get Krav
mcgraw so she could knife a dude's neck.
Yeah.
But I mean it's like,
it's not like,
you know,
that didn't exist.
It was like sexual assault started in
2014.
I mean like,
stuff like that is about what has always
happened and uh,
and then also,
you know,
it gives you like confidence and it
really is all you gotta do.
You know,
there was elementary,
middle,
and in high school and you know,
I feel like somewhere in junior high you
just had to have one fight and fight
back and then it was like prison and was
like,
oh,
I don't,
you know,
he's going to be a problem.
And then they would just move on.
And then the kids who never fought back,
um,
it's,
they just have these horrible variances.
Um,
so I dunno,
I just,
you know,
it's just one of those things,
as a parent,
I guess what I meant is like,
now that you're a parent,
you thinking about things differently
possibly and with kids and with your
daughter,
I mean,
how has that changed?
I would say I am applying the things I
always thought about because I,
I've,
because for all these years of not being
a parent,
I would watch parents,
you know,
dressing their kids in certain ways and
I would just be like,
how do you not see that?
That is that the shit that that kid's
gonna get,
get it right.
You know what I mean?
And it's just like for the love of God,
can you give them a fighting chance?
Yeah.
So like,
um,
yeah,
I,
I think you,
you,
when you grow up,
you become one and you either completely
forget your childhood or you have a
pretty vivid,
hmm.
Murray of it and I,
you know,
it's most,
most of my channel is positive.
That's an interesting observation.
Yeah.
I feel like I forgot most of it.
That means it probably had a decent one.
Right.
Or the good ones,
the one you forget.
No,
no,
because I had,
I had no good in a bit.
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't know what though.
I'm not a psychologist,
but I just think like the people I've
talked to,
they either like remember everything or
it's just like,
dude,
that was a long time ago,
man,
I don't remember.
So I think if you don't remember and
then you have a kid,
you know,
I wouldn't want,
I would rather be the kid and the parent
that remembers.
Right.
So how do you forget my mother said the
forties actually was kind of
heartbreaking.
We don't,
my daughter is only a year and a half
and she was going,
I just really enjoy these first three,
four years as she got,
she goes really enjoying before they go
to school and you know the kids ruin
them.
Like wow.
That's like one of the funniest and
saddest things you ever said button.
And then I was thinking like,
why did she think I was ruined?
And I probably was on some level.
That's an interesting that she
remembered that after all these years.
Well because he came home from school
ruined.
Yeah.
But just going to send your kids to
school with,
with people who have kids that they're
not actively involved in their life.
And so then the kids acting out and
there they,
the kids on his way to becoming a
problem and then your kid sees that
behavior starts to mimic it.
Like I,
you know,
a lot of my friends obviously have kids
that are older and they just,
Oh yeah.
Like it's just kids that are just,
uh,
you know,
the key is not to get mad at the kid.
You got to get mad at the parents know
if you ever want to punch the kid,
you don't do that.
Right.
Don't punch the parent.
Punched the,
when dog I,
I'll give you a tee shirt.
I just got that.
But yeah,
I mean I say we dogs now because we have
a dog and we go to a dog park a lot and
things like that.
And like it's always the owner.
The owner is not always,
but sometimes,
yeah,
sometimes.
But I mean,
I dunno because dogs,
I feel like there's this pure sweet
souls for the most part.
And they have to be fucked up kind of by
the owner to be really or dangerous
animals.
There's the dogs that nature says no to,
but people say yes to because it's
adorable.
And then you like the mother just,
there's an inherently knows that there's
something fucked up with the dog,
kicks it away and the thing's going to
starve to death.
And that's too heartbreaking as a human
being in a dog lover to watch.
Okay,
so you give it the bottle and like,
you know,
then one day you see it's got one red
eye and the other he got the terminator.
Well,
you're talking about like an adopted dog
or like a getting a puppy because I feel
like when you adopted dog,
you definitely throw the dice a little
bit,
you know?
Um,
I had a rescue dog so that,
that was the other pit bull that was my
experience yet.
And we ended up having to find her a new
home.
And fortunately it worked out,
but she was a human aggressive as they
say.
I spent thousands of dollars trainers
and all this types of things like my
trainer.
And it ended up taking her and it has
been like the challenge,
I think of his dog curry.
One of the trainer adopted the dog.
Yeah.
It took incredible.
Has He,
Ted's,
he managed to tame the animal.
Now he's been working with her for two
years and she,
she's a,
for the first time in her life,
has another dog friend.
But he was the one who said,
you know,
this is one of these dogs.
Nature said no to,
but people said yes.
He goes,
I'm thinking that that's what it is.
But she's an absolute,
she's one of those people,
like if she was just abandoned again and
then came in here and then met the three
of us once,
she'd be all timid.
And once she saw that we were cool and
we're going to,
once you fed her and protecting her,
she loved you and she almost love to
hard.
Right,
right.
So then,
and then she would treat everybody else
who came through that door.
Yeah.
Like they were an ax murderer and we
would just never,
I mean,
so I had all these things I used to,
uh,
one of my buddies,
a forest,
we used to just go on hikes and it took
forever and ever and ever and ever and
ever.
But he was really good with animals and
she ended up accepting him and it was
the longest,
you know,
and I had to do all like come back to
the house and just,
just have him,
you know,
stop at the gate.
And then it was a little bit behind the
gate and then up to the front door.
And then,
and then there was all the,
him walking in first and just any little
thing could cause like a setback.
And it was,
uh,
it was,
you know,
it was emotionally draining.
Yeah.
I mean,
yeah,
she ended up buying one of my friends.
I always keep thinking of that Mama and
she raced Adam.
There was a pocket,
I should have kicked it because he was
so,
she was on like a hardwood floor.
I went and knocked her down,
you know,
he would've been just fine.
Was he her?
No,
she barely,
cause she hadn't done that before so she
didn't,
but,
but how it works is at first they go to
the feet,
then they go higher and each time as
they build up and then it's fight and
then grab it.
And it just,
you know,
it's sort of like an escalating like
alcoholic.
Um,
I mean I'm talking kind of,
you know,
I don't really know a lot of this stuff
and there'd be a bunch of people right
now.
So I'm just talking about what my
experience was.
I'm not saying I know everything about
dogs,
so,
but that's,
that's kind of I was afraid to adopt
because you just never know what you're
going to get.
And people give a shit.
Cause we bought,
we bought a dog.
We wanted,
we wanted a purebred puppy or not a pure
bed,
but we really liked the Maltese and the
Yorkies.
We have a friend who had to military,
so,
and we really liked them,
so we were like,
so we've got a file.
Can got a falcon.
That's the only thing.
Multisite.
No.
Oh it was a maltese.
Just a little fluffy white dog.
Oh,
it's a little toy dog that you can pet,
but we get so much shit for having
bought a dog,
but it's like,
you know,
you throw the dice when you,
you don't know what these dogs at the
pound has been through.
You know,
it's like,
uh,
I mean,
were you supposed to do just what was
supposed to have a puppy mill ones?
These dogs need to be a Bot.
Somebody's got to take care of these
dogs.
I mean,
you need to,
you need to know what you're doing when
you can get a rescue to train them.
Right?
I mean,
I don't,
yeah,
for me,
for me it's my first dog,
so I don't want to gamble too my chin.
But it's because it feels like you,
like when you're walking down the street
with him and people be like,
Oh,
where'd you get him?
And you didn't buy that dog.
You,
it's like,
if you care that much,
sorry,
this is something that bothers me.
If you care that much about adopting
dogs,
how can you have a kid?
You got to adopt kid,
right?
There's kids out there that need a home.
How dare you have a kid of your own if
you're not going to adopt first heard,
same logic.
It's basically a puppy mill.
Yeah,
I agree with that.
Thanks.
I got,
I got bills and toys to map.
My theory has been,
if I was in your situation,
I would just annoy the shit out of
people.
I would call volunteer it.
Well,
I got an a thought.
If you're a Brit mean.
Yeah,
it was like the least sick we looking
one.
Yeah,
I figured I'd get that one.
I love that.
Yeah,
you just steer into it.
I love that.
I need,
that's why I was,
I was over in France and like I'm trying
to learn how to speak French.
I have been bad with it,
but like when I would go over there,
you know,
if you stink,
they just start speaking English.
And I was just like,
well,
if I get to listen to the English,
you're listening to my French and I
would just torture him with it and I
would not switch over.
And it'd be like,
I speak English and I speak French.
I speak French.
Okay.
This is the situation or the smart way
to do it.
That's the way to learn.
Yeah.
What else am I going to learn?
You know,
I lived in Israel with Isla for five
years and I succumbed because every
time,
you know,
they're like,
oh,
this idiot American,
I'm gonna speak English to them.
And I succumbed,
I didn't steer in.
I wish I steered it.
You got to,
you got to get into the comedy of it.
Just fortunately them with their own
language.
It's really funny.
They maybe look at immigrants
differently,
like,
uh,
but I guess it immigrants,
it's worse.
It's worse because they're actually
staying,
you know what I mean?
So I would be like,
I would be like the fact that I'm going
to be there for 10 days.
I'm not trying to get employed,
kind of give a fuck and I just have a
good time.
Um,
I don't know.
I had a great time at a great time doing
that.
I need to get a shirt that says I bought
this dog.
Yeah.
So you probably never spent much time at
a dog park because there's a whole thing
there,
but it sounds like your dog would have
just gone on a rampage there.
Probably she was all right initially,
but then once she sort of bonded with
us,
then it became a problem.
So no,
we stay,
I stayed away from there and then,
then everybody else who watches like the
dog whisperer in that and then they
tried to be the guy running the
shirtless up.
Yeah,
everybody does it.
They didn't even know what it is.
See if you would've stayed through that.
I did that for a while.
Like the magic was making that noise and
it's just like,
no,
this guy's been working Walcott ever.
Does he even know anything?
I also wonder does he just pretend like
he knows and then we believe him.
You know what I mean?
I don't know.
I mean you're right.
You're really,
I mean he's doing this.
I mean how much,
what does that do?
Well I think the guy knows what he's
doing.
Okay.
He got a TV show.
There's people he did,
but he worked with a lot of famous
people's dogs.
No famous people got eaten by dogs.
So I would say some level nuts.
Yeah.
You're really cynical guide man.
That is a lot for me to say that I'm
cynical either the bill birth yet,
but you're not,
you know what you're not,
it's going to close.
People think like I listen to your
podcasts a lot and you are,
you're a very optimistic,
fair guy.
There's like a real fairness behind
everything you say.
It's nice to be listened to every once
everybody else go.
Like you know,
he's the king.
I'll rage common.
I think cap guns.
Cause you know,
I used to be a redhead before it left
me,
but I still have the red beard.
There's just something about like,
you can sort of openly say that redheads
or the child,
children of Satan and that's,
that's totally fell all good.
It's all good.
Kick of Ginger Day.
All that fucking that bother you though.
Like for real,
all the data and does it,
it just,
it,
it's freeing because then I don't have
to care about whatever you're crying
about.
And particularly white women complaining
about how difficult it is to live in the
United States of America.
This is hilarious.
You know what I mean?
I mean look,
if you some hillbilly living on a dirt
trail then yeah.
Okay.
I would feel bad for you.
But like other than that,
you have,
you know,
pretty much having red hair.
No,
no.
It's,
it's just more like,
uh,
not have red hair thing is,
it's a myth dude.
I did great too when I was single.
I did great.
No,
it was confident.
I was funny girls.
I did fine.
But this whole fucking thing that I was
like over,
over the corner,
um,
I mean it's suck when I was growing up.
Yeah,
definitely.
Cause it's like you got a bullseye on
top of your head.
So,
but I feel like I,
you know,
I always joke with people,
if I had like brown hair,
I wouldn't even be in this fucking
business.
That's great.
I don't think it would be funny and I
think I wouldn't be be,
you know,
just doing some big cog in a wheel
somewhere then a dental,
uh,
dentist possibly as your father before
you write your dental assistant.
Yes.
That's interesting.
Well,
I mean it's not that interesting.
It's interesting if my dad wasn't a
dentist when,
right.
It's like,
well,
did you have ever plans,
like before you got into comedy,
what,
at what point did you decide you wanted
to get a comedy when you were doing like
dental assisting?
Or was that just kind of,
you always knew you wanted the job?
I needed a job and I got fired,
uh,
from this warehouse because,
it was this,
this fat guy who was running,
she was from the carpeted area.
Right.
And he used to come out,
you know like the typical Douche who
could like just gets a little bit of
power and it just,
I don't know why and then they just go
pure evil,
pure evil.
But he just,
he just walked out there like he had
accomplished something like,
I don't know what like he had like an
astronaut sort of gait the way he was
walking.
So he used to come out there and
everybody would seem common and then try
to like work it,
oh look at me cutting up the box and
look at me,
you know,
doing this shit.
And I just met [inaudible].
I was like,
fuck this guy.
So I wouldn't do that.
And if anything I would,
I would step off the gas a little bit.
But yeah,
it was up man.
Damn,
I didn't do that.
What do you get the,
where do you like it was self sabotage
because I have no other option.
I feel like everyone wishes they had
that right there where you're like,
you know what?
Fuck this guy.
I'm going to work less.
I don't have that in me.
That has loved it,
but that has to be applied correctly.
Right.
Cause it'll stop your life.
You need to work as a team.
There's a plane crash and maybe we
should go this way.
And I've gone,
oh no,
it was just cuff sucker lead me out of
the woods.
But like not fuck everyone.
It's fuck these guys that don't deserve
my respect.
Well,
yeah.
So I didn't work as hard and then I,
and I was due for raise it and then I
asked for a raise and then magically I
got laid off and the economy was bad and
I couldn't get a job.
And uh,
I needed,
one of my dad was like,
well why don't you come work with me for
a little bit?
And I did and it,
and it was,
it was great cause I got,
I got,
I worked with him for five years and it
went wow.
And I got to a sort of,
you know,
by not seeing my dad,
just seeing him as a dentist,
like I kind of got to figure him out,
um,
and understand them more.
So it was a great thing.
And then also I learned so much about,
you know,
teeth and all of the headaches that he
can cause uh,
yeah,
I don't think I'd still take x rays
because they switched up the machinery
so long go since when I did it.
But I could still take impressions,
pour 'em up.
I still don't have the old school way.
We tap on that vibrating thing to get
all the apples out of it.
It's nothing worse than if there was a
fall because the bubble would,
they always seem to go down to the
bottom.
So it then another one would always be
right where the tooth was and then like
the bubble wouldn't take the w would
kill that impression.
Uh,
that part of it.
And you'd have to talk about when you
put like the clay in someone's mouth.
Yeah.
And then you can't just report because
the,
that gunk shrinks and then you have to
Redo it.
And then if you had a gagger and you had
to read it,
and I will fucking guy I puked at the
dentist when they took her.
Yeah.
I was a gagger man.
Broke my heart.
One of those bubbles popped in my mold.
Yeah.
There was just like,
I used to just,
what are the kinds of crazy shit you
deal as a,
you ever getting people's mouths or were
you just on Stan?
Yeah,
it took out the stitches and that was
certified to take x rays and uh,
yeah,
it was about the extent of it.
So when did that,
and then did an end when you started
doing comedy?
No,
I was doing,
I was doing dates and I was,
and it was hilarious.
My Dad,
you know,
back then he had like,
he worked from seven to seven.
I never saw anybody.
We had a 7:00
AM patient used to work on like,
like prisoners,
people in the correctional thing,
cops.
He would work out.
Yeah.
He like,
he was like a force of nature.
Like he did the work of three dentists.
So I wanted to work with the other
dentists because it was just like I
could actually get a lunch.
We used to police to numb people up.
I'd be numb people up and then race out
while they were getting numb.
And just wolf down slice of pizza.
Oh,
you'd be on your feet.
The whole day is just like,
no,
I got my work ethic.
Both my parents worked extremely hard
their whole lives.
I mean,
they're older now,
so they're retired and stuff,
but like,
uh,
but just watching how hard they worked
and I think that that is one of the main
reasons why I got this gig coming up in
New York was,
um,
you know,
it was a combination of,
of learning.
That's what working is.
And then coming up in the Boston comedy
scene where like what was considered
killing there.
MMM.
You know,
what was considered just getting the job
done was killing and some of these other
cities that I went to,
but like they're,
so it was just laying in grounds.
Yeah,
no,
they murdered,
it was a guy,
Kevin Knox,
rest his soul.
He used to host the show and uh,
patrice rest his soul.
He used to say,
uh,
Kevin doesn't host a show as much as he
just like,
takes breaks from killing.
So he would like murder and then you
would,
and we used to compare it to like a
giant wave.
You'd get up there and just find a ride.
And he really took it personally,
if you bombed on his show because he
felt like the crowd looked at him like,
Kev,
you fucked us.
Like who was like,
like he took it personally responsible.
Like he was the GM putting together a
championship team.
So,
and we used to tell horror stories about
having to follow,
which you have to follow with star trek
bid or is drunk driving bid.
And they were just all,
they all murdered.
And um,
so yeah,
it was probably,
you know,
that whole thing.
So I have a very low level of patience
for people that dog it at their jobs.
And I don't give a fuck if you hate your
job,
just going in there and just not doing a
good job.
It's just like,
I just,
just like then Quinn,
but like don't make everybody else
around you suffer.
Like it's,
it's Kinda like,
it's bullshit.
Like you signed up to do this job,
do the fucking job.
And,
um,
and I really don't have any sympathy for
people who don't work hard and,
uh,
okay.
You know,
and they're not getting where they want
to be in life.
If you're making an effort and you're
still getting fucked and that's like
somebody,
I'll try to help out.
But like if you're just like
not putting in every minute
yeah.
You're fucking over the person you're
currently working for and then ask him
like where your brass ring is.
It's like,
well,
I mean,
that's not how the world works.
What,
what is the C,
you've probably heard this a lot.
People say that dentists are like high
rate of suicide.
What is,
is there something to that?
Have you heard that?
Okay.
Uh,
yeah,
I think everybody heard that growing up,
but I never knew when that true.
I've never known one that killed him.
Yeah.
Did you,
well,
it sounds like it was stressful,
but not suicidal.
Yeah,
obviously.
Yeah.
He never killed him yet.
He's,
he's,
if that's what you're asking to kill
themselves,
it's just the oprah part.
Where you going to try to get me to cry?
Yeah.
Well,
I got nothing done about it one night.
I just thought that was interesting
thing.
It's just one of those things you hear
and you're just like accepted it on face
value.
You're like,
oh yeah,
dentists,
they're all killing themselves.
Yeah.
That was all of those things.
And that was the thing.
The guy who put the pack of firecrackers
in the kids back pocket and lit it and
blew half his ass off.
And you never heard that one,
that these might be older ones before
your guys' time.
But there was a,
there was these think candies called pop
rocks.
Oh yeah,
I know the pop box.
So the thing was somebody swelled a
whole bag and his stomach exploded and
he died.
Like all of those types of things
existed.
So I don't know what the new ones are.
Right.
He was on his ipad and he fell asleep
and he burned his face trying to update
the technology.
That's a good one.
I think that's true actually.
I heard that.
Um,
so let's take a quick break.
We're going to go to a quick commercial
break.
We got a lot to get to.
Am I coming back after the [inaudible]
coming back?
Uh,
guys,
are you coming back after the break?
I certainly hope so as well.
Stay tuned.
Thank you to dollar Shave Club for
sponsoring this episode.
Now have you guys seen pulp fiction?
You know the scene at the end of that
movie where he opens the briefcase and
it's glowing gold and you don't know
what's in it?
Well,
I finally do know what's in it because
dollar shave club look at this or look
at these packs of one wipe charlies.
Oh my God.
First of all,
this has nothing to do with the
copyright.
I just wanted to give him a shout out.
Oh Man,
I can't wait for that smell to be
replaced with the putrid sent my rotting
asshole.
Got Enough about that.
Let's get thank you to dollar shave club
because you guys already know whatsapp.
You got to look and feel and smell and
have your asshole smelling the very
best.
They got it all boys.
They got toothbrushes,
toothpaste,
and of course razors and shaving butter.
That's how I get ready.
You've got to get ready with dollar
shave club because they've got the best
products.
You don't have to go to the fricking
store is the most affordable guys.
I don't know what we're missing.
We're all guys,
right?
No.
Oh.
Oh,
there's girls too.
Guess what?
They also need to shave and brush their
teeth.
So what are we all doing?
They've got the answers right here.
Dollar Shave Club.
Okay.
And right now you can get ready with an
amazing deal on any one of their starter
sets.
I recommend the daily essential starter
set because I love the amber dirt
lavender body cleanser.
Why do they make me say that like I love
all their products.
Why do you specifically,
are they well anyway,
that one is amazing.
Their marketing find it.
Let's call it something specific.
Yeah,
the lavender.
C'Mon guys.
I just thought this is the one.
It's the one wipe Charlie.
All right,
but you can't go wrong with any of them
and that I do agree with.
Head on over to dollar shave club.com/hd
to pick up your own dollar shave club
starter set for just how much?
Five fricking dollars on the table.
Okay.
Gimme a break after your starter set
product ship at regular price and make
sure you check out their new video.
Two,
that's dollar shave club.
I don't know what that video is.
It could be something really obscene.
I don't know.
Probably not.
That's dollar shave club.com/h
$3 shave club.com/h
three guys,
they got the best razors.
They got the best shit.
They got everything.
You fricking need $5 on the table.
Try Dollar Shave Club.
Thank you to mint mobile for sponsoring
us.
I love this product because phone lines
are so ethic expensive.
It's ridiculous.
I remember when we lived in Israel and
when we were dead broke,
there was a phone companies that were
selling their product for like $10 a
month and it saved our law like it's
actually saved our life.
We were so broke and here if you want to
get a plan,
it's like a hundred fricking dollars.
It's insane.
So that's what I'm so happy to see meant
mobile because they are that disruptor
that's given a good service at a fair
price.
Okay,
now I want to read this coffee they've
got cause it's hilarious.
There's sin in shouts out to the world.
The big and big wireless p stands for a
lot of things,
big contracts,
big bills and big fees.
Oh,
what's up now?
Shots fired like eight t and t's new
$800 million administrative fee
increased meant mobile doesn't have
around with any of that shit cause guess
what?
They cost just $15 a month.
Wow,
that's a game changer,
dude.
They make it so easy to cut your
wireless bill down.
All they do is send you this card in the
mail and guess what?
You know what that is?
It's Sim card.
You plug in your phone,
Bob's your uncle,
$15 a month.
I'm telling you,
it changed my life when I had this
opportunity in Israel.
Choose between two five 10 gigabyte,
four g lte plans,
no more paying for unlimited data that
you don't even need.
Every plant comes with unlimited talk
and text.
And if you're not 100% satisfied,
mint mobile has you covered with their
seven day money back guarantee and t did
you ditch your old wireless bill and
start saving with mint mobile yet?
It's about time guys.
Go right now.
Set up your new wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month plus free shipping on
your Mint Mobile Sim card.
Go to mint mobile.com/h
three that is immense.
mobile.com/h
three cut your wireless bill of $15 a
month and get free shipping on your Sim
card.
Guys meant mobile.com/h
three guys,
they are listening and they are watching
and this is not me being paranoid.
They're out there lurking,
ready to steal your data right now.
Who is they?
If you need to know who's they,
they are already ahead of you.
They the government,
the ISP,
the people sitting at the airport being
like,
Oh,
free airport internet.
Cool time to steal your passport,
your credit card.
They Ila or all out there and they're
praying on the weak lambs of the world.
That's why you need to get express vpn.
You're making online purchases are
accessing your email to an unsecured
network or even from home cause the ISP
can see everything.
You're making a big mistake,
okay?
You were being tracked.
Expressed vpn has easy to use APP that
runs seamlessly in the background of any
computer,
phone,
or tablet.
You turn on express vpn protection.
It takes one click,
boom,
protected you later.
Haters.
I was going to flip off the camera,
but I thought maybe that's too obscene.
Um,
express vpn secures and anonymizes your
Internet browsing history.
Everything that's going on,
encrypt your data.
Hide your public ip address.
You are set to go,
okay?
Forget about Hentai.
Okay?
We can live with anti.
The government doesn't care if you're
watching the head or whatever it is.
Even weirder than that.
What I do care is that people don't get
my credit card information.
Don't get my passport,
okay?
This is the kind of things that are
important to keep secure.
I don't want to be another stat and
facebook's advertising campaign or
Russian propaganda machine,
okay?
Protect your online activity today and
find out how you can get three months
free@xpressvpn.com
slash a tree that's exp,
r,
e s s v p n e x p r e s s vpn.com/h
street for three months free with a one
year package.
Visit xpress vpn.com/
[inaudible] to learn more.
Thank you.
We are back with the great,
great,
greatest bilborough.
I do mean that,
but I know it makes you uncomfortable,
but one great was bad enough.
Does it bite you?
But you know that I like being
appreciated.
Yeah.
Okay.
Just say Tony,
that one with the person I appreciate.
Oh really?
Yes.
Back what?
He's worth the money.
Okay.
It's definitely worth the money guys.
Madison Square Garden.
Yeah.
What was that?
A November 7th and New York City guys.
Head on over to bill bird.com/events
and I do want to say,
guys,
you all have netflix.
I mean,
everyone has netflix.
Statistically half of Americans maybe
even more have netflix.
That's incredible,
right?
That means that everybody should be
watching.
Episode fabric is for family saving.
More people have it considering how easy
it is to steal somebody's right
password.
So I would say probably they don't care
about that.
That blows my mind.
I mean I think that's like this,
this gi level loss like it's,
yeah,
but then we'll get them addicted to it
someday.
Someday that relationships fail and
they're only going to be halfway through
narcos and they can have to see the
ending and then we'll get their account.
But like they were so ahead of the game
because all these companies with
passwords with access,
there are so tight ass about it.
They'd be like,
Oh,
you can only log in to computers that
wants netflix going back a decade said
no.
Everyone on the block,
everybody,
you know can use your account and look
at them now.
Who's fucking laughing?
No,
I guess they are.
F is for family guys.
Check it out and left.
And now I'm uh,
I want to show you some videos.
Okay.
I thought I would like,
I don't know if you're going to like
this one.
This one,
I don't know.
Save.
It was risky but risky.
I don't know.
We'll see what you think.
This is the old classic.
You may have seen it.
You don't have to say anything.
I just want you to enjoy it.
Okay.
Is that a move?
You know this is
us.
Check us out.
That was incredible.
You want to do that again?
That was like break dancing right there.
No,
that's a move.
That is absolutely his face got kind of
probably kind of roughed up.
I think that's absolutely a move.
They face grind.
Watch him watch.
I'll control the is,
I don't know dude.
[inaudible] second you slide on your
face.
You don't want to be,
your arms are going to flail.
He was just like,
well they have a different center about
hockey snap.
Like if it's a move then that's all we
knew is just watch his arms.
Watch his arms.
He was pushing to to try to get another,
I mean is the foot that they're ahead of
the game.
All right guys,
I want to see more of those.
Well,
I've never thought about it as it being
a movie once again.
Great,
great.
Mine is.
I appreciate it very much.
That's just and move both the baseline.
So here I want to ask how nuts to the
crowd go when he did that.
I mean it's still,
we got to the gate.
What are you going to go right?
I got plenty of little people are and
what are you going to go there?
I got what you're finishing.
Why the face slide,
the face,
whatever you want to call it.
The Deli face.
Yeah,
exactly.
So I want to ask you about one of the
great moments in your career or one of
my favorite moments in your career.
And then I,
I've always appreciated only with pop
this up for reference for us,
the audience I want to ask you about
Sherry's berries,
it ketchup going up and it's sweet
holiday gift.
So you had a,
I'm just going to catch on one up.
You had a advertiser called Sherry's
berries and while you were reading the
copy you just,
you couldn't hold it together because it
was the first time reading the copy.
It was just so homophobic and homoerotic
if the same time that I just,
it was,
it was so silly,
I couldn't move.
It was actual cop and it's just so
ridiculous.
The it like I've never heard anything
like that being advertised.
Evidently they're delicious.
Still still make hot chocolate.
Yeah.
And they dropped me after awhile.
You know what happened was I had Harris
Stanton was on and they was like,
we have strawberries,
you know,
drip,
dunked in white chocolate and then
they've,
we have,
you know,
in dark chocolates like oil.
And I've just jokingly said to him,
he's black.
I said,
how come the white chocolate comes
before this and that?
Then we started riffing on the Klan or
something and then,
I dunno,
I dunno.
Then it was just two people can fit it
off.
Strawberries are made by the clan.
I didn't know what they was saying.
Yeah.
I'm still sad they left.
I loved going share.
Yeah.
I mean Dude,
how many ads go viral?
I've been thinking about,
I've never bought cherries,
berries.
They told me to take this down and then
cause I,
in the end I said,
you guys better buy this shit cause I'm
gonna get in trouble.
And then people bought it and then they
quickly were smart enough to be like,
okay,
leave it up,
leave it up.
And we had this really cool thing where
I felt like cherries,
beer,
they get me,
we won't happen if somebody new came in
or maybe somebody saw black klansman.
Mm.
The,
the original cut of it.
Right.
You know,
before it came out.
Now I don't know what happened.
What do you love?
Or maybe I'm gonna say we listened to it
so many times.
It's like one of our,
oh thank you.
I love,
so let me,
let me update the,
the audience here with a little Sherry's
berries.
Yeah.
Well,
so have delicious products such as
Christmas cake pops,
cheese cakes and dip pretzels is the
only way to get this special.
1999 Sherry's berries offer call eight
six six fruit.
I'm sorry,
what the fuck am I?
So did I have proof of this?
This is fucking ridiculous.
Who the fuck is going to buy this shit?
fruit.
Yeah.
I love that so much.
So did they?
I W I really just wanted to know how did
they react to that.
But it sounds like they reacted like
you'd have to be like laughing.
It's going to take it down.
Yeah.
And um,
well I have this thing on my part.
I never talked to the advertisers.
I never available.
And if like yeah,
either get what I do or you don't.
And I understand,
I understand if you don't want to be
associated with her,
my stupidity.
But if you do,
I think I can help you sell some stuff
like the bear.
Well,
the thing is is people can fast forward
through the ads so the show can't stop.
So you got it.
You got to do something to make a one.
I like on Howard Stern,
I love when he burps during the region.
It just,
it always makes me laugh and it always
sounds like the same one like red stew
in it.
But I,
uh,
it always makes me laugh whenever it's
just something hilarious about somebody
burping while reading advertising.
So I actually look forward.
I look forward to is reads,
I look forward to your reason.
I love listening to your reads because,
well,
let me ask you this.
Do,
do you get in trouble a lot when you do
read,
because a lot of your reads or like I
was listening to your,
one of your recent podcasts,
you were talking about sports betting.
You're like,
I don't like,
I don't fucking sports cars.
They make you say like [inaudible] on
his buds.
Like,
I don't,
I don't do this shit.
They'd be like,
words in your mouth maybe like you bet
you when I'm like,
yeah,
well you lose and your wife leaves you.
There's degrees.
So the sponsors get upset with your
candidate.
No,
I think at this point that gets kind of
been established.
This is what he does.
Good stuff.
Yeah.
So they'll just be like,
they like,
I haven't lost an Avatar,
I shouldn't say this,
but I haven't lost one in about three
months.
Four months.
Yeah.
So that's been a good run.
That's good.
That's a good run.
Good one.
There's always like my favorite wine,
which are going to the hall of fame of
the One and dones.
I'm trying to think who they were.
The only one I could ever remember is a
box and I thought,
I thought,
I know what happens.
I thought it was nature's box,
like the best of it.
So I was like,
you going down on Mother Nature,
right?
Yeah.
So stupid.
As you're laughing,
I read another three lines of copy and
you're getting information and they just
didn't see,
they didn't find the humor.
We had nature box.
I think they went under actually.
Yeah,
most stupid.
They're just like bringing,
we weren't,
we failed them do it bringing you a
banana and it's just like,
well,
I mean I could fucking,
I can't do this yourself.
Like what they were offering,
it was just like hacks with snacks,
snacks,
snack.
You Take Guinness to 45 seconds out of
your day.
You can probably do this yourself.
You ever get asked for make goods when
you do ads?
What do you mean?
Like,
if I screwed,
they say,
they say you got to do another one for
free because you messed up the first
one.
I don't recall anybody ever talking to
me in that tone.
They don't fuck it up day.
Yeah,
you guys,
you got to do another,
you got it free because a no one's
lucky.
You still live in fucking punk.
Yeah.
So let me tell you someone,
we get the shit all the time.
I don't get this.
I don't get that respect.
You don't get what?
I don't get that respect that people ask
me for me.
Get again to the Oh no,
you'll,
you'll get no,
I know.
There was no,
this has been shit that I've screwed up.
Um,
but I said there's a buffer between me
and them,
so I love that.
So Andrew,
who runs,
it'd be like,
yeah,
listen,
these guys,
they were a little upset about it.
It's just fucking read it again.
It's like,
all right,
cool.
I'll read it,
but I don't get the whole whatever.
Sit Down Mafia,
sit down that you get.
So you did get them read it again.
I don't know.
You don't even know.
Ignorance is bliss.
Yeah.
It's not to call you ignorant.
No,
I am making.
Right,
but you don't.
But I'm smart enough to know that you
don't talk to your advertisers there.
It's like I didn't get into podcasting
to do a conference call with you fucking
guys talking about this shirt you're
trying to sell.
Like I get it.
It's a shirt you wrote.
What you going to say?
Just like,
I don't want to listen to you guys.
Like do you just trying to fill up your
day?
So many people in,
in those fucking corporations,
they just trying to justify that desk.
So then the,
the whole,
I hate when the conference call ends and
then you hear this voice that you
haven't heard the whole call and it's
like you were afraid that everyone was
going to hang up and you didn't say yes
and now you're in a panic mode.
So then they just throw something out
there and you have to address it.
Like,
it's a legitimate comment w when it
isn't,
it's just like,
you know,
go through a lot of those because you
went from being working kind of day jobs
to doing comedy full time.
I presume barely do them anymore.
But I used to,
I used to do,
when I had conference calls on scripts
or anything,
what I would do would,
I would put the phone on speaker and I
would throw it to the other side of the
bed and then I would go,
she got video.
I would literally lay on the bed,
like with my arm across my eyes and I
would just wait for people to stop
talking and then I'd just be like,
yeah,
you know,
it sounds good.
So I don't know why I can watch so many
hours of sports yet.
I can't even,
like,
I can't handle more than it.
They drive me insane.
Um,
well I like texting.
You don't phone calling someone on the
phone.
It's almost like an insane thing to do.
These,
it's like rude.
It's like,
dude,
what?
Unless you have like sort of sort of
intimate relationship.
You know what I mean?
If I call it you loads,
it's important.
What happened.
If I call him,
if I thought,
if I call Isla to Chitchat,
that'd be weird.
Jail.
If he called me,
I was like,
hey,
how you doing?
I'd be like,
okay,
what?
What is it?
You know what I mean?
Like I feel like since we've,
we had the kid,
my wife finds me calling her man.
No,
it's annoying because she either is in
the middle of his shit storm or she
finally got a break and then my dumb ass
is going to be like she,
she this Guy Sean supermarket,
she just like,
I just feel,
I just want my,
I got 10 minutes.
This list.
Yeah,
so she's a trooper.
Oh,
I wanted to tell you about this make
good we got and I think I need to remove
myself because it's actually drove me
crazy.
It was funny though.
They said,
I said,
when I was doing a copy read,
get your free trial for $5 but what was
written was for 95 and they said,
you have to do it again for free because
you said $5 instead of four 95 you
should've just said,
well,
I'm not doing that.
We did.
They said,
okay,
yeah,
okay.
Yeah,
that bluff and they're holding nothing.
Yeah.
You have to do it again for free.
No,
I know,
but no,
it is totally a game of being better
because you went higher,
so now all my God,
I just save the nickel.
I love this fight.
Exactly.
It's a twist.
Yeah.
No.
If you said like you know for 50 then
they find out is for 95 then they have a
45 cent.
Now we've got a problem,
man.
Okay.
Yeah.
Now you have a conference call.
Now nobody's going to chime in on that
one.
Hmm.
How do I,
as a fan of your podcast,
the Monday morning podcast,
everybody who was not listening to the
Monday more podcasts,
please do because it is my favorite.
How do you prepare for that podcast?
Because you sit down and get talk and I
swear to God it's like you're doing
material.
But yeah,
no,
you're just talking.
But like I always wonder,
how do you prepare?
Do you prepare at all for your podcast?
I,
uh,
Andrew sends me the advertising,
copy it,
I copy and paste it and then he sends me
the questions for the week.
I copy and paste that and I stick it
under the ads.
I never broken down my whole game thing,
my game film.
And then what I do is I'll just write
pats game,
you know,
topics,
big feet,
blah,
whatever.
And then I just start talking and uh,
if it's not going well,
I go to the list.
If it goes great,
I barely look at the list and all of a
sudden I looked down and I've done like
a half hour and a half or even done the
region.
I know that the question goes one,
I'm going to take like,
uh,
20 minutes or so and um,
yeah,
that's basically how I do it.
No,
but through wound,
you're going throughout the week in
between podcasts,
do you take notes of Shit you want to
talk about or do you sit down and you're
like,
oh,
I remember that.
I won't talk about that.
No.
Like I need a side on topics as I just
sit down and I just thought and I'm just
like,
ah,
fuck what happened to me in the last,
I know something happened and you can
build the anecdote about like,
uh,
you were making a sandwich and the lady
was,
she asked for a special thing and the
lady was just like,
no.
Oh my God.
But,
which was so funny,
but I would remember because you know
what I hated about the guy was he was,
he was on his tip toes watching.
I wanted a Bagel and I feel like they
can visualize,
they wanted butter on them and you know,
it's just fucking airport.
Yeah.
And they've got like the little,
the little,
you know,
little conveyor belt thing and they sent
it through and he's,
he was just sitting there like,
like a mere cat.
Right.
And,
and he was just annoying me because I've
had that job.
It's just like we just met him,
make the thing and be done with it.
And he just said,
oh,
could you,
could you just put the butter on it?
I would just put the butter on it and
she's,
and she was just like,
she was like a,
like a grisled vet.
She was just like,
what?
Can you just,
I was just wondering,
can you,
can you put the butter on it now?
You know,
before I go to register,
she goes,
oh,
the buttons over there.
And he goes,
no,
no.
I was just hoping,
can you spread it now?
So like,
cause it's still warm.
I want it to be melted.
Can you do that?
And she just goes,
no,
I love that fucking laugh.
And I looked there and she just looked
at me and be like,
half a cigarette hanging out on him.
I'll say,
what do you want us like ham and cheese?
But I guess that that mammary was you,
you,
you have a good memory I think because I
don't think I would have held onto even
even something that precious.
But you've always got,
I mean,
you do a twice a week too,
so there's a lot of time to fill,
but you somehow capture these memories
and retell it in a way optic,
you know,
I got it.
You have the tower clip.
My favorite little bit up on my podcast
is because I'm making my wife laugh,
which is my favorite thing in the world.
She has the greatest lots of cute and
thank you.
I can be adorable.
That is like my pocket.
That could be a horrible every once in a
while.
Um,
I told her this story of a,
I first told the story of watching this
old guy wipe out on a scooter sliding on
his face.
And then it reminded me of this time I
saw this guy,
um,
this guy in griffith park was in street
clothes and went down the steepest hill
and wiped out and I was telling the
story.
It was like a Sherry sperry thing that
it started making me laugh and then my
wife started laughing and you know,
that story that listening heard her
laugh.
That's why we got married,
that,
that whole story,
right.
The chemistry and that whole thing.
Like I,
I listen,
I'll go back and I listened to that like
once a year and a no,
I feel lucky that I met somebody that
has like,
she's as funny as most comedians I know,
and she has an incredible sense of humor
and um,
it's kind of a,
it was,
yeah,
it was just something that,
you know,
someone like me,
a lunatic,
I needed someone like that,
that could laugh that hard if somebody's
falling off a skateboard.
How did you guys meet,
by the way,
you and your wife?
Um,
well,
she's in the business.
She worked on,
um,
Chappelle's show,
but she didn't,
I was on season two.
She was on season actors or no,
she was,
uh,
um,
what was she on that,
I forget what she was on that one.
But on,
on tough crowd was when I met her.
She was a talent coordinator,
but she also was an actress.
She's been interactor than I am.
Every bit is funny.
So she's like one of those people that
is so good at everything.
It's trying to figure out which
direction to go in where I am a one
trick pony.
That's not true.
Uh,
if you really look at it,
if you look closely,
yeah.
If you look at the credit,
wow,
this guy's all over the place and
they're like,
hey,
you got a TV show fucking break.
Give me a break.
Yeah.
And I play Frank Murphy,
who's allowed screaming jackass.
I do stand out loud screaming jackass.
I do my podcasts in the movie.
Jack be driving over here loud screaming
jackass.
You're planning,
you see DC AC DC,
three courts.
But seriously,
the movie does seem to not to be a
departure from the loud screaming
jackass.
Which movie?
The one that's going out in front
runner?
My God.
Yeah.
I mean I saw it from the trailer's not
that much information,
but you seem to be playing a very
sincere detective.
Did I understand that role playing a
reporter.
Oh,
your report.
Okay.
Who works for them,
who mysteriously still possesses my
Boston accent and mean,
well hugh grant,
who I think is going to get nominated
for an Oscar like in between takes is
speaking like us.
He's Australia and that's what he talks
like and then an action and then he's,
he's fucking Gary Hart.
That wasn't nice.
I find that amazing.
I probably shouldn't,
it's because as opposed to me who just
memorized his lines and tries to make it
sound believable.
Well I can't wait to see that movie
looks really good.
It really,
when I saw the trailer office,
uh,
it's amazing.
I have to start learning everybody
else's name in it because I,
um,
I was only on it for a and with a
limited amount of actors because
everybody just crushes it.
It's a bunch of,
you know,
to me that kids,
I'm 50 so they're all in their twenties
and thirties and I was just like,
you know,
I was kind of watching and going like,
hey,
here's the next batch.
Like these men and women are going to be
be doing stuff.
So I'm very happy for all of those
people.
Are you,
it's hard to tell from the trailer,
but is it a major role in the film or is
it more of a like kind of secondary
character?
Uh,
more like a 14th.
Okay.
Alright.
Do you want to act the more movies you
seem to enjoy it.
I love it.
I really,
I,
it's,
it's weird now that I have a kid,
but I learned on that one that the next
time I'm just going to rent a place and
bring my wife and kid.
That was,
yeah,
that was hard.
Oh my God.
My kid today was coolest thing ever.
Like she occasionally now speak since
we'll do two words,
you know,
if she's not shy or anything like that.
So she had to get one of her shots today
and she's been over there a bunch of
times,
so she knew.
So she would go to the doctors and she
was like,
you know,
getting all nervous,
like,
like a dog going to the vet.
So,
you know,
they're gonna shoot it into a little
cute little thigh and like she's sitting
there and she's like,
ah.
And she shot her and gave her the shot
and she starts crying and she goes,
okay,
it's over.
When she say,
yeah,
she looked at the nurse,
she goes,
oh,
done five,
five.
Oh,
I like broke my heart.
And I was proud that she said three
words and she totally communicate.
It's like,
yeah.
It seems like you're in love with your
daughter hearing you talk about her on
the podcast quite well.
You've pretty perceptive like a carrot
more than that.
Okay.
Because again,
you're this character,
you gush,
Gush over your daughter.
Not everyone.
Gushes did your Dad Gush over you?
Uh,
I mean I was too little.
Yeah.
Now my dad was,
my dad actually at worked it at work.
That's what I learned.
Like,
oh my God.
Yeah.
He really likes us.
Oh,
when he came home,
Hey,
he was cracking the whip your bed mate,
you're doing your studies.
Well,
why not?
You know,
is that shit?
And uh,
he also had a zillion kids,
so I mean,
yeah.
How many siblings do you have?
I don't know,
Dude.
The Internet's too fucking weird to give
out all that information.
You don't even want to say how many
because you're afraid that it will
optimize your talking about it.
Is there anybody you can cut this out?
I'm honest dude.
Like seriously dude,
I,
yeah,
this fucking lunatics out there.
Okay,
well off the year,
off the year.
I'll tell you.
Alright,
cheese.
I love how surprised he is.
Chief actual lutely crazy.
Keep walking.
No,
I'm not.
What I gotta do,
what you have to do is just consistently
lie and changed names.
I actually,
I do have friends that do that.
I don't think I'm smart enough to do
that,
but I have friends who are youtube burns
their front facing persona that everyone
knows them by their name and everything
is a complete fabrication and they're
brilliant.
I wish I thought about that because
we've had creepy people coming to our
house,
the same assholes that created a lot of
this spy where shit like if you're
already thinking that,
oh,
they just had a,
or they are smart,
you know?
But yeah,
if I could,
well I could never do it all over again
because of what I do.
I need social media.
But if I wasn't,
um,
you know,
a performer,
if I was a manager or anything like
that,
I would have a website but I would not
be on social media at all.
Interesting.
Yeah.
All right.
I don't know why that's so flat on my
part.
Tell me about,
uh,
all things comedy.
I Dunno.
You say I'm nervous.
I'm sweating here.
I'm just going to let you sit.
I know you are.
You don't have to save me.
You got to push through to the other
side.
No,
I know,
but you're not touching elliot.
If you are a lever on the other team,
I'd have come out and check you for
vaseline or something.
You punched your hair and you feel a
little too many times.
He's doctor in the ball.
Shit.
Alright.
Regroup.
Um,
Jackie gleason.
I think I have a question about your
[inaudible] you being in that and having
a kid.
We have been trying to have a kid and
the longer it takes,
we also kind of second question the
whole thing,
like should we have a kid?
It's awesome.
It's one of the few things that truly
lives up to the hype reel.
All these years of being lied to about
the summertime movies.
The good thing is it's awesome and uh,
you know,
what do I know?
I'm only a year and a half fence.
So my year and a half experience has
been incredible.
And the only advice I would give you is
don't listen to 90% of other parents
because for some reason they take a joy
out of trying to ruin the experience.
Saying like,
Oh,
you wait,
is your first one is going to change?
No more drinking.
Oh my God gets leave now it says they
just hit you with all this dread and I
was walking,
I was just gonna be like,
you sound like a terrible father.
Like you don't sound like you're
enjoying it and that road,
no.
Well why didn't you say all that
positive stuff?
You contin,
you know what I mean?
Like,
that's just,
it's just how people just like to
complain.
No one shit trying to like a pass on the
knowledge.
It's just like,
but in an annoying way.
Yeah.
No.
Like for the optimist,
I'm telling you.
No,
I got a lot of sweetness in it.
Yeah,
no,
I,
yeah,
I'm,
I am not what people think.
I want to ask you about all things,
comment.
You've got what,
what is all things comedy?
Is it a production company?
Is it a podcasting network?
I mean,
this is a company.
It's every,
it's everything.
It's first it started off,
uh,
you know,
years ago we were watching the whole
podcast thing exploding and then
watching what always happens,
like the artists create a seed and then
the businessman comes in is like,
okay,
here's the deal.
I'm going to wrangle all this up.
I'm going to own it,
but you're going to get all this
exposure and you're going to have to tap
dance for the rest of your night and I'm
gonna have a fucking yacht in five
years.
Right?
So we're like,
well,
why,
what's stopping us at this point?
The technology had come up about where
you could actually start your own thing.
And there was podcast networks out there
where they,
they were doing this thing where they
owned a percentage.
Oh,
of it.
Yeah.
Owns your podcasts.
Worked with telling everybody going,
dude,
don't get,
you don't have to give that away.
But like,
um,
you see that kind of stuff on youtube a
lot too.
Right.
But,
but a lot of people from my generation,
you know,
in a weird,
like a prison kind of thing.
You were institutionalized where you
just thought,
I can't own anything.
I need to go to bigger thing.
It's like,
no dude,
you have your own tv right here,
your own channel.
Um,
so we tried to do more of a Co op where
everybody owns the thing,
um,
owns their podcast and uh,
yeah.
So that's basically what,
and we all hype each other's projects,
offers these,
um,
when the guys are network network from
the diversity effect podcast,
when he had his first comedy cd come
out,
we all tweeted about it at the same time
and put out a great album and that came
together and he went number one on
itunes and [inaudible] both the United
States and in Canada as an unknown at
that point.
And now we just produced a,
a standup special for him,
uh,
for comedy central.
And comedy central has bought,
uh,
three more hours from us.
So we're going to produce so now and now
we kind of get to pick and choose people
that we like these guys,
men and women that we think are
hilarious.
So,
um,
and uh,
so then,
you know,
I'm currently writing a movie and you
know,
we,
we partnered with soapbox films and you
know,
you know,
I'm writing with somebody who isn't with
all things coming,
but if he likes it,
we're going to drive it through there
and just kind of build this thing up.
And the whole thing was,
you know,
uh,
to do this,
trying to do it the right way.
It was was quite a task,
but we just,
we just don't,
we wanted to have comedians to have a
frigging rail light that they could go
to where everybody wasn't just trying,
you didn't tell him to fuck you over
like on like on specials and stuff like
that.
This shit that goes down really that,
yeah,
that stuff that goes down it,
you may like pie slices of the pie going
and all different directions and like
people haven't side deals with networks
that suck or going out of business,
you know,
that's something that we ran into and
it's just like,
Hey,
every specialty you bring us to,
you get,
you get 60 grand.
So then all of a sudden this guy 60
grand,
it's not going to tell you,
hey,
go to this shithead network instead of
that instead of like a Netflix or
something where it's going to be seen.
Yeah.
And it's just like,
I'm like,
yeah,
that's only the tip of the iceberg.
And then like,
you know,
expenses and all this and all this stuff
and like sky high expenses with no
accountability.
Yes.
All of that type.
Well the thing was,
you know,
back in the day it was like,
I swear to God there was some people
that literally had like insight people
like tmz has at the airports and say,
you know what,
celebrities are going through.
Like they would literally have insight
people to network and they would figure
out what your budget was cause you get
in business with a production company
and you'd be like,
what can you shoot this for him?
It's like,
well how much money you got?
well I'm gonna fucking tell you that.
And they would somehow,
I swear to God,
like if you had $1 million,
they'd be like,
oh we did the budget is gonna be like
999,000
and then if you had like nine bucks,
it'd be like,
he's gonna be $8 and 99 cents like that.
They are,
they're always like vacuumed up
everything.
But that final fucking 8%.
And then you know,
that they went out and they shot the
thing for like 70.
Yeah.
Like not even probably whatever,
whatever the number was.
And they just skimmed it.
Just took it not skim and dude,
they took a giant some fucking shovel
out of there.
And um,
you know,
I,
that's the one thing that,
that they only like the one thing that
has been really a disappointing getting
into the business world because I know
it's not just the business that I am,
but just the level of what you say the
business world.
You mean own being and don't just
thinking because entertainment business
has a bad rep,
but it's just straight across the board.
The uh,
the level of c I just unabashed stealing
that happens in business and they
justify it.
They sleep like babies.
Yeah.
It's,
it's so rampant that I don't even,
I don't understand people that like
steel,
like you,
like anybody,
if you're a thief,
like you should be working towards
getting on the legal side of stealing
because there's probably more stealing
on the legal side of stealing.
And now you don't have to hide the car.
It's all above board or whatever.
And it's just like,
you know,
you see things like a lord of the rings.
It grows like,
I don't know how many billions of
dollars a year.
Like the director had to like sue,
like the better Jackson suit that they
didn't pay him.
They right.
They were saying they were not in,
in uh,
profit.
And it's a routine thing.
I'm learning this,
you know,
writing a movie.
It is,
it is a routine experience to be in one
side of,
um,
what are these big conglomerates
pitching the sequel will while in the
other side of the building and the legal
department you're suing them for not
paying the first of that is so fun.
Yeah.
And just like auditing and all of that,
all of that with what they have.
This shit I've seen,
I've been through these clubs were like,
you can audit us and if there's less
than a 5% discrepancy,
you have to pay for it.
Five is good.
I usually get like 12 how do you,
how do you fuck up paying me 12% yeah,
so and then all it's accounting,
it's numbers.
Then you have to pay for the audit you
bought.
So they kind of gave themselves a
license to steal exactly.
Eggs that that's all that means.
I saw my first constitute what we
legally owe you but,
but we're going to write this so we can
steal this and then if they really
greedy they'll actually go like beyond
it.
No,
there there are some,
well they have nothing to lose click and
characters out there.
The first time I saw that clause I was
like,
okay,
so I have a 5% discrepancy,
which means you're going to take 5% more
than you are and that is considered
being difficult if you say that.
Yeah.
That's the,
which to me means what?
Difficult like difficult to steal from.
Yeah.
That happened to us all the time because
in youtube in the beginning there was so
much not going on and we would not let
it slide and say,
hey,
we've got a youtube channel.
I remember they had this thing where if
any of your videos get flagged then you
can cock sucker can take your revenue.
Well they said you don't get the
advertisements.
I said,
oh,
so you don't run the ad?
No,
we still run it.
Well then he fucking gets it taken it
what it is.
Some would have a whole team of people
youtube just flagging shit now are,
that's what they do is like the,
I'm,
I'm dealing with this shit all the time.
What happens is if you're a copyright
holder,
and I mentioned you like we have a video
just talking about something and I
mentioned a clip,
right?
Maybe I show it for a split second.
So they've got people,
probably just some interns,
low-level grunts that just claim it and
they get the money and they make so much
money like that cause they just math do
it.
Do you know,
my thing is when they're in the meeting
and they present doing that,
they presented like they are on a good
mission.
Like you guys aren't there and they're
basically presented how they're going on
a crusade there.
Copyright.
That's what they,
yeah,
we have to protect our copyright because
there's all these pirates online
stealing content and we're standing up
for ourselves.
No,
but I'm saying like if,
if they feel like what you said was
offensive to somebody,
they would flag it like,
oh yeah,
then I shit,
it's just like that's going to be every
clip.
Yeah.
It's frustrating.
But yeah,
it's,
it can be really frustrating,
especially when you spend like a whole
week working on a video.
Cause that's a lot of youtubers will
post like one video a week.
Right.
And then all of a sudden some assholes
just like mine.
That's my money now.
How cause they collect,
they'll claim it because maybe showed
some of their work and there's a fair
use,
which means that you're allowed by US
copper about ripping people off.
I'm just talking about you put up your
own original content.
Yeah.
Talking about,
you know,
no,
it's,
it's original content.
But if we talk about something like a
news way or reacting or talking or
criticizing,
you know,
sue him,
you can do,
yeah,
but you up.
But then you have to get that rep out
there that you do that it,
this is the bullying thing again.
Like,
I don't,
I don't fuck with the h three podcasts,
man.
These guys don't go sue you.
It's not worth the headache.
Waveband thought I lost a really big on.
We didn't win.
You won.
Won.
That's great.
When's the movie coming out?
Man?
I went out real good movie.
It wasn't feeling good at the time,
but it was,
uh,
you know,
I don't give a shit if you're recovering
from that,
but I'm sure this is light goes on and
show business as well.
I don't know what goes on straight
across all the other business.
Yeah.
War All the way down to the business of,
of a standup special.
It's like the people that are always,
you know,
with the shovel,
not skimming,
shoveling money out,
they're such fucking rich.
They're so rich all the time too.
And it's like they just cannot be fair.
I Dunno.
Yeah.
That's the thing.
Like,
I just wish I could talk to him and just
like ask them,
well,
I mean I'm,
you know,
I'm not a perfect person.
I maybe that's just,
you know,
where I fuck up in other areas of my
life.
Maybe this is just their thing,
but I,
I just,
you know,
fucking some,
college kid out of the money on his,
on his page,
I don't know.
Or some new comic on a special.
And so anyways,
that's those,
it's basically,
that's why we started,
you know,
all things comedy and now it's just
grown into this thing.
We,
uh,
you know,
we're going to produce some TV shows
who's starting to sign some deals and
yeah.
And it's like a management,
uh,
no,
you represent them.
No,
no.
We're all conglomerate.
Yeah.
And we'd like a production.
We can also like,
um,
uh,
you know,
whatever you would want to do,
the soapbox films they laid,
they literally end to end.
It's a,
a union.
Yeah.
The edited,
like the muppet movies and all of that.
These guys can handle any bullshit idea
that I ever have in there.
So,
um,
while all the comics are,
I love,
I mean you got,
you have so much talent there and your
youtube channel is amazing love.
Actually.
We're doing us.
Something's burning.
Burning.
Oh thanks.
Bertine.
Yeah.
Or crushed.
This is why I'm here.
He told me,
he goes,
you got less burden.
He's such a sweetheart.
Um,
do you watch you two videos at all?
Yeah,
I love Youtube.
Really?
How can I do I want,
um,
I like lions killing hyenas.
It always annoys me that they fucking
come over and they take the shit,
you know,
and then the lines ended up in the tree,
uh,
justice,
my own idea.
I watch anime.
I watch a lot of musicians videos,
like nobody's doing drum covers of songs
and they'd be,
oh,
I'll watch them and maybe I'll learn
something.
Um,
you don't follow you tubers.
I feel like there's two types of people.
There's like people that,
cause there's so much great stuff on
Youtube.
Look tutorials and documentaries and
stuff.
I watch that shit.
I,
I don't get it like you want,
it annoys me.
The worst is when there's like a,
say something happens like,
okay,
so you were showing me that clip or
whatever.
The little fellow there slide known his
face,
right?
Yes,
the face grind.
So it's just like,
it'll just say little person,
epic face grind.
Right.
And then it comes on and all of a sudden
this guy,
okay,
you're not going to win.
I'm always like,
shout out the face man.
He fucking face.
And it's like this isn't even your
fucking content.
And like there's so many endos so I'm
sure I haven't seen the good ones
because there's an art form to all of
it.
But I always just feel like it's always
like,
you know,
eyebrows up,
super high energy guys,
check,
can you believe this?
Well then he starts to show right before
now watch this.
I mean this dude was like,
dude,
I fucking get it.
It's like someone who doesn't know how
to tell a fucking story and things
should be over in like 30 seconds and
now I got to sit to fucking three
minutes.
He get bullshit.
That is kind of a meme on youtube was
like the tutorials where you're like,
okay,
I'm going to show you how to use
photoshop.
And then like 10 minutes,
20 seconds.
Then after describing his whole life
story,
he gets to the point now he knows the
worst.
It was expert village.
Oh I love that.
You've been around.
Excellent.
Rich.
What the fuck?
I want to show you some of my favorite
expert that was playing guitar and so
expert village Ozzy and it was always
wrong.
Hold on.
Always stuck.
The expert village was a phenomenon.
I love it.
We made one of my most cherished videos
about expert.
Exactly.
Nobody wasn't that.
They were [inaudible] about like how to
make a cheese melt and then don't,
don't put it in the microwave for 30
seconds.
And that's the thing.
Wait,
I got to show you how to flirt.
I hate it.
And then they would like,
they were like,
you couldn't get away from him for
awhile.
Like you'd go to a search and then all
of them.
Cause you mentioned expert village,
I think it's important to bring you,
show you what's up here.
Okay,
look at this guy now.
I've now this video I love because look
how much dead air there is.
Okay,
well it's not.
That's not hitting.
He'll get blamed.
That's not his fault.
Well,
either way they uploaded it.
I mean they could've cut it for Christ's
sake.
It is his fault because I think they
make the video and then they submit it
to expert village and then expert
village puts it up.
So here we are.
Size
is the lighting with his shadow on the
back wall to look at that.
You getting seduced tie.
This is how we got no sound.
Oh,
I'm a social dynamics instructor.
And on behalf of expert village girl at
a bar,
how to flirt with the girl picking up
women in bars and clubs,
flirting.
What is it?
Hmm?
The basics of flirting is to convey
through certain ideas and emotions that
you like someone else and hopefully that
the other person likes you back.
Now who are the best flirts in the
world?
They're actually little kids now.
Why is that?
Well for one thing,
they did the best imaginations I was
already feeling.
Basically,
you know where the sexiest people in the
world,
little kid
sandbox and then talking about some
fantastic place that they can go on the
wall,
on the wall in their mind to put
themselves in a place that's just the
two of them and their own special world
using their imagination.
Also little kids or how do you do that
as an adult?
They're realizing
rape drug and it made her drowsy,
but you're going to get to the what?
What do you want me to shell?
Oh,
we're news.
Like the eyeball thing I,
it's just,
it's kind of a long time.
The words,
if I see a girl with blue eyes,
I might say,
wow,
your,
your eyes are like blueberries.
Wait,
can I actually can actually I'm kinda
hungry.
Can I,
can I have,
that's one thing that you could go into.
Can I stick my fingers in your,
I thought he was so hot.
You know,
who are the sex,
you know,
who are the best flirt?
When he said,
Oh my God,
your eyes are like blueberries,
blueberries.
It was the wrong word.
Vibe was good,
but then you start doing the little into
the Karen.
It makes me feel really calm to squash
your fucking eyes.
These are their experts anyway.
Love expert village happy.
You miss that.
Hey,
you remember this lady?
Let me ask you about this.
I like,
I like to wash your hands.
You like this.
You remember this lady?
No,
I haven't.
The fail videos,
the woman's stepping on the grapes and
that was falls off like that was just
somebody who never had the wind knocked
out of him before and so she didn't know
it.
Stop talking.
So she's you,
you know,
I used to hear that
on Howard stern all the time and I never
know what it's from and I thought it was
like a crazy orgy sound like I never
knew.
And then when I saw it,
I got f obviously I got to pull it up
now.
Uh,
she's smashing grapes,
right?
Great Lady.
Ric flair videos.
Great.
Here you go.
This is it.
Good enough.
If you could find the original,
this is it right here.
These buckets are filled with grief.
What kind of grades either filled with
shame or thin gray.
And the winner this Saturday you stomped
the most juice will actually when an
overnight stay or shot the alarm when
you're ready to try it.
Yeah,
sure.
That'd been in a group.
You're,
you give us a 32nd steps though.
19 million.
Good measure.
I mean it is kind of one of them.
That's the thing he's ever done a juice
it the metric overnight.
Alright.
And if you,
if you,
when you get to stay a short line and
what else do you have going on in here?
Come and spend the day lag.
Getting international,
having wine tours and tastings and your
tour's seminars,
arts and crafts.
It's a lot of fun.
A whole day.
Stop.
How?
Wow.
Oh no
lives.
Just to put those things up on that
platform.
That woman is how I got to hold his
shoes up there.
I can't be all that sound man.
I love it.
You can't beat it.
You remember this slide you have to do
talks about her or they didn't play
enough.
But I want to show you,
I want to remind you of this,
this great.
There's like your hands to hand model.
Like to say that my hands look good
naked.
They are really just the perfect,
neutral,
toned hands.
So that the hand model is,
and it's a very even tone while heading,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I guess creepy,
creepy shit.
Wow.
This is good stuff.
That's stuff that we've made videos
about.
I'm sorry.
You're very protective of her house.
What else was going on?
I want to ask you about this.
Um,
this is one of the first time I heard
about you.
I was in college,
I think at the time it was when you were
getting booed by thousands of people.
And I was like,
when you said my favorite youtube video
is like,
Oh God,
not the philly thing again.
And then you did the Sherry's berries.
I was like,
I love this podcast now.
I hate you.
I love,
what can I do?
I love that joke and I'm fucking with
you.
Do it.
But no,
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna ask for,
I get that boat.
But Barb,
you've,
you've talked about this a lot.
Probably more than the grape lady.
I didn't realize.
No,
but I go ahead.
Let's do it.
Skip it.
I like making them,
well,
what am I,
what am I going?
Yeah,
right.
And now what do you want me to be?
Well,
what was going through your head bill,
when you're good by all those people?
I don't know.
I don't remember what was going through
your head.
No,
I'm kidding.
This is going to end up on youtube.
This is lie.
This is going to end up on youtube was
what I was what I was thinking.
Cause everything else on the tour was
ending up on youtube so that,
um,
yeah,
I guess that's what was going on.
So no,
I think I thought that afterwards and
I'm like,
well that's going to be embarrassing
because I didn't know how people were
going to take it.
I thought people were just to say,
oh,
you got booed,
you fucking stink and blah blah.
I didn't know that people were going to
find it funny.
Fortunately they did.
You did kind of win the audience over.
Did you feel that while you were on the
stage or was it just like,
these people hate my guts the whole
time?
Because it was no
thought it was a complete failure.
I have no idea.
Uh,
yeah.
Well,
I don't know how many of our fans have
seen it.
I've got to pull up a clip.
Okay,
go ahead.
Go ahead by God.
We should skip this.
No,
no.
Go ahead and push the skin.
I should have been more of,
I should have been a better sport.
No,
you're a good sport.
You're doing your thing.
You're being authentic.
You're authentic.
Now this is just going to,
now this is the kind of thing that
somebody who buys a dog does,
right?
Yeah.
Wow.
Really?
Get me deep down.
Get down to the ground.
Um,
now this is just going to be about me
being uncomfortable showing you this
video.
I imagine there's a bunch of comments
though.
Now going half.
Fuck you.
The Eagles beat the Patriots.
I would think that there'd be a bunch of
that.
Someone these to animate this two years
ago,
but the video quality is fucking weird.
Anyway,
they all Bujo I,
yeah,
all you guys get it.
But for me that was my first heard about
you.
Was that a big moment in your career?
Like a,
did you get a lot of recognition with it
cause it kind of went viral back then?
I mean that's the first time I heard of
you.
Uh,
yeah.
Um,
well I got,
I got,
um,
you know,
respect from other comedians,
which was probably the thing that I
remember most.
But um,
as far as like people coming out to the
comedy clubs to see,
I don't think that that happened.
I,
the reason why when I started drawing on
the road was because I did a,
uh,
I did a half hour on hbo and I was
sitting in for Jim Norton on the opiate
Anthony show cause he was doing,
uh,
Lucky Louie at the time when Louis Ck
was at hbo.
So I kind of had those two things hit at
one time.
And then so I was able to kind of get
the coasts in ONA,
mark,
not,
not the south,
but sort of,
I had the east coast and then I had like
San Francisco,
I could do well in and then open it.
They were good right through like
Cleveland.
So an opiate anthony also would run
like,
uh,
you know,
they,
they didn't have the budget at Xm,
I think it was back then to pay us for
our appearances on the show.
So they would let us literally cut
commercials about where we were going to
be and they were really funny and it
was,
you know,
it was one of the cool,
like it was really cool that they did
that and it was a major reason why,
you know,
all of us started selling tickets.
So I really missed that show.
I really do.
How did the comedians react?
Because I remember some guy tried to
Yankee off stage towards the end it was
like,
hey,
how about the next comedian that
happened?
I don't even remember that here.
I got it.
The thought.
You've seen it so many times.
Why would I want to relive that?
I've never seen get out.
Let's get,
let's get,
I've known.
What else?
I had a headache for like two days.
I've been really,
really well.
You were really stressed out afterwards
about it.
I was,
I remember walking around New York the
next day looking at people thinking of
insults.
It was not a,
yeah,
it was,
it wasn't a wholesome experience.
No,
you get booed by 10,000
people,
so you just kind of getting that fight
or flight mode.
So I was kinda stuck in the,
I remember riding home with Robert Kelly
that night.
It was like being nervous about like
that.
It was coming out.
He goes,
dude,
you realize what the fuck happened
tonight.
You just told the whole city of
Philadelphia to go fuck themselves.
And I was sitting there going like,
man,
when that shit hits you too,
tomorrow everyone's going to laugh at me
and just be like,
oh,
you got booed stats.
See,
that to me is interesting because when I
watched that I'm like,
it's this.
He's on fucking fire.
And he's authentic and it must feel
incredible to tell 10,000
people to go fuck themselves.
And like the most polite way,
it felt good to do it.
But I,
the perception of it when I left was
what I was,
I was worried about.
I mean I was,
wasn't,
had just started selling tickets in
places and then all of a sudden there's
this clip and then it's going to live
forever on the Internet of me getting
booed and there's,
there's stuff up there of comics having
bad sets and it didn't help them.
And I'm thinking like,
that's going to happen for me.
I mean,
how do you get booed and it helps your
career?
I mean,
I don't,
I mean in this case that did,
but I mean I didn't have any reference
to them.
He gets booted.
She was like,
Ooh,
you suck.
Get out of the fucking business.
So I was worried if people were going to
understand the kind of crowd that I was
in front of.
Having said that,
like I love Philly crowds and I also
love the city Adam happy,
you know,
it's sucked up.
My team lost to him,
but I was really happy for them that
they finally got a superbowl.
Hmm.
Well I loved that moment.
I love everything.
You do the great,
great cause I turn it around.
Turn around.
Well we're old.
You uncomfortable that you fucking sit
there and compliment me.
I almost made it through,
I think in ask them myself.
I got so close.
I had a great time.
I did too.
I really did.
I hope you did.
I'm worried about you.
I'm playing it up.
Alright.
But I plan on trying to be funny,
but uh,
we are all worried about him.
Oh my.
No,
it got real doctor and you got something
to live for,
right?
She was just looking at dogs guys.
Hello?
We sat with him.
He's a great one.
Bought them.
I bought them from a mill by the way.
Yeah.
And you said,
I appreciate what you people do here at
this pub.
Well,
a instagram photo.
Do you gotta do that?
You steer ready with the receipt area?
Me Fit the puppy mill.
You can't believe how many dogs do you
have here?
Oh Man.
By the way.
It was kind of,
I was surprised when I went to the puppy
mill.
It was a nice wholesome experience.
That guy,
he really cared about the dogs.
The dogs.
Who did he know you were common or?
I gave him a call and you said you were
coming.
Wow.
People popped in while we were there.
You think they're just like on chain,
like he was just,
you didn't see the Bait dogs and all
that shit.
Actually it was a breeze.
It was more of a breeder then.
Like a mall?
Yeah,
puppy.
In a shredded newspapers situation.
How many dogs are there?
Only two.
They won the week and another one sold
out.
No more inventory.
There you go.
You know they outlawed a puppy mills in
California or not cow in Nla.
You can't sell puppies and Los Angeles.
You have to go to thousand oaks or
Orange County.
How about that?
Didn't know that.
All right.
That's amazing.
I wondered why at the Beverly Center
that pet store went away.
Yeah.
I thought it was because of people
reacting to that.
Some reason you don't care about the
fish that are in there though.
The durables and all those other things
that used to be free.
We only care about dogs.
It is true.
Well dogs need something cause they took
the wolf odd of them.
So they need somebody to kind of help
them along.
My dog would not last a day.
No,
not even an hour on his own.
He would be,
you ever seen when they take the fangs
out of a Cobra?
No.
I mean I know that doesn't know that.
So it's still like doing all that shit.
Well that's how they do.
You never see that one with the baby
just goes up and grabs a snake.
They liked,
they did a thing where they like,
I don't know if they sowed it's fucking
mouth shut.
It was.
It was brutal.
Yeah.
But the first time you see you see this
baby crawling up to a Cobra and you and
you're like freaking out and then they
just,
it's like grabbing onto and the cobras
like basically like headbutting most
aggressive lights blocked.
Bad lesson for a baby.
By the way.
Don't play with snakes.
Yeah.
You would think that would be the
direction you're going on man.
You know,
like they somehow get pregnant.
Right?
Cause that he's supposed to say it.
You get pregnant like you are a
seahorse.
Right.
Um,
just yeah,
just steer them away from the snakes.
Have them resend back the snake,
respect the snake river.
You Little Shit.
And this is my house.
I'm running stuff wrote down.
So I want to thank bill burke guys,
go to [inaudible] dot com slash events
he's playing at Madison Square Garden
November 7th.
I'm excited for you.
I'm thrilled.
It's going to be a great show.
Everyone get there.
If you've got Netflix,
which I know you do,
if you don't have it,
your dad,
your girlfriend,
somebody has got to,
for Christ's sake,
washF is for family season one and two.
Three is coming out soon.
Yes.
And of course the wild west,
Vince Vaughn,
Peter Billingsley,
Mike Price,
uh,
Victoria von,
everybody that a,
it helps me do netflix and everybody
helps me do the show because I think
this is going to be our best season.
Of course.
Uh,
yeah,
it's all good stuff.
Cool.
So guys,
thank you so much for watching.
I look at the camera to you.
I don't think they can see you.
We show,
yeah,
show bill.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
We'll see on Friday for a top of the
week.
We got a lot to talk about and kill
telling me.
I don't know if you're acquainted with
those sweet guys are going to be
hearing.
I know.
I know those guys.
Very,
very funny gentlemen.
Good people.
Yeah.
All right.
What are you going to say at the
beginning,
Tony,
you are the greatest,
greatest,
greatest comedian I do.
It's everybody.
Everybody's.
I don't,
I swear to God I don't,
but you know what I would tell him,
you know what?
I have to call him.
I'm going to say I appreciate you
telling me.
I'm going to tone it all the way down.
I'll tell you I love his car.
Okay,
I will fucking,
now I'm curious.
What is this Karma?
We'll talk about that.
Yeah.
Yes.
On Tuesday.
Okay,
cool.
We don't the great bill bird doesn't
have time for that.
All right.
Bye guys.
Thanks for watching.
Thanks for item.